Hey Thoughty2 here.
At some point in human history, we realized
that if we left the cave door unlocked, someone
might come along and steal our collection
of bear skins and our favourite rock.
So, what was the solution?
We couldn’t be everywhere at once so perhaps
we needed a group of people to watch our cave,
prevent rock theft and make sure no one rode
a mammoth too quickly through a pedestrian
zone.
Unfortunately, although rock theft declined,
this new cave watching group became suspiciously
well dressed and were getting all the best
bits of antelope at the nightly barbeque.
Police corruption has been an issue throughout
the ages because as the Roman poet Juvenal
once wrote “who watches the watchmen?”
Good policing undoubtedly makes our lives
better and easier but it’s a difficult balancing
act to get right.
So whether it’s making money on the side,
avoiding blame for suspicious wrongdoings
or a belief that the end justifies the means,
today we look at four massive police cover
ups from around the world.
Los Angeles has a lot of gangs and, if it
wasn’t for all the drugs, violence and murder,
the amount of diversity on show would almost
make you proud.
There’s the Bloods and the Crips, the Wah
Ching and other triads, the unimaginatively
named White Power group; Nazi Lowriders, MS-13
and plenty of other Latino gangs.
There’s also the terrifying Los Angeles
Wargamers who’s army of Dark Elves and endless
grain resource cards have terrorised the board
game community for years; you can take their
lives, but no one will ever take their virginities.
To tackle this smorgasbord of criminal sub-groups,
the LAPD assigned each division an anti-gang
team called Community Resources Against Street
Hoodlums, or CRASH, which began in 1979.
When officer Kevin Gaines, of the Rampart
division, was shot by an undercover officer
in 1997, the subsequent investigation revealed
a police unit that didn’t just have one
or two bad apples, the whole barrel was rotten.
The Rampart scandal revealed that the Rampart
CRASH team had planted false evidence, performed
unprovoked shootings and beatings, stolen
and dealt narcotics, lied in court, committed
bank robbery and more.
In trying to give gang members a lengthy rap
sheet, they had actually written their own.
A number of officers moonlighted as security
for the hip-hop record label Death Row Records,
which had links to the Bloods gang.
It’s possible that some of these officers
were even involved in the execution of Biggie
Smalls.
The LAPD had a real mess to clean up and eventually
paid out $125 million in civil lawsuits, disciplined
around 25 officers and a handful went to jail,
including Rafael Perez who snitched on all
the other officers in exchange for a reduced
sentence.
On 15 April 1989, the worst disaster in British
sporting history happened at Hillsborough
football stadium in Sheffield, when 96 Liverpool
fans were crushed to death during an FA cup
semi-final game.
Nowadays, every team in the top two leagues
must have all-seater stadium, largely in reaction
to this tragedy.
On the day, two pens with Liverpool fans were
already very full but there were still a lot
of fans outside the turnstiles when the game
was close to kick-off.
These fans were all directed into the overcrowded
pens and the ensuing jam of people crushed
everyone so tightly that many suffocated.
Initially the fans were blamed.
The Sun newspaper, owned by Australian media
vampire Rupert Murdoch, printed a front page,
headlined “The Truth” that claimed Liverpool
fans had pickpocketed the victims, urinated
on police and even prevented them from giving
CPR to the injured.
All of these were proved to be completely
false and The Sun newspaper is still boycotted
across the city of Liverpool to this day.
But it wasn’t just The Sun who were wrong,
the police, led by David Duckenfield on the
day, spent decades pushing the blame onto
drunken Liverpool fans and fans without tickets.
Duckenfield claimed that the fans forced their
way in through a large exit gate, when in
fact he himself had ordered it to be opened
to relieve the bottleneck that was building
up outside, ignoring the fatal crush happening
inside the gate.
In 2012, an independent report was finally
published, bringing the truth to light and
in August this year, an investigation began
into Duckenfield, revealing the police force’s
utter disregard for people’s safety on that
tragic day when 96 innocent spectators were
crushed to death, because of negligence.
There are even reports that the Freemasons
had a hand in allowing the disaster to happen.
Now we head to the heart of the Caucasus,
the beautiful country of Georgia.
After the collapse of the Soviet Union, Georgia
was in a pretty bad state.
It may have had hundreds of stunning mountains,
a rich history of wine making and a national
food called khachapuri (“Ka-cha-PUER-I”)
that is a bread boat filled with cheese and
topped with a fried egg, but sadly, in this
sick and twisted world, that is not enough.
Large gangs controlled much of the country
but that all changed when Mikheil Saakashvili
(“Sar-cash-vee-li”) became president in
January 2004, following the non-violent Revolution
of Roses in November 2003.
He promised to end police corruption and gang
control.
And he did, by scrapping the entire police
force and starting again.
A fellow revolutionary Batu Kuteli explained
the reasons for this radical overhaul when
he compared tackling corruption to “building
a ship in the middle of the sea while sailing,
while also learning how to sail, and while
you have somebody attacking and trying to
sink your ship.”
Excellent point, you can see why they got
the boat…
I mean vote.
The trouble was, his new force were a little
too motivated and before too long corruption
was gone, because they basically locked everyone
up, ending up with the highest per capita
prison population in Europe.
In March 2006, police claimed to have prevented
a riot by the inmates in Tbilisi prison, organized
by gang leaders.
But they did it by preventing seven inmates
from continuing to live, as well as injuring
17.
There was also mass surveillance, telephone
tapping and torture.
There are a number of big British secrets,
such as; why do we eat marmite and why do
we play all of America’s super heroes in
films.
But the story of the Mau Mau was one of our
closest guarded secrets, where the actions
of the colonial police and military in Kenya
were mostly suppressed for over fifty years.
In the early 1950s, the native Kenyan population,
particularly the Kikuyu people, thought that
the British might relax their occupation a
little, especially after the Kenyans had fought
for them in WWII.
Obviously, they had never been overly delighted
at being colonized, people are often not as
grateful as you’d think when you move into
their house and eat all their food, even if
you do have an excellent collection of moustaches.
A rebel group called the Mau Mau appeared,
killing around 200 Europeans and colonial
sympathizers.
The Brits used propaganda to paint the Mau
Mau as evil boogey men, framing their activity
as part of a civil war among the Kikuyu.
In order to protect loyal Kikuyu and control
the rebels, they moved over one million Kenyans
into village camps that were effectively giant
gulags, with living conditions dependent on
how loyal they believed each person to be.
They use white settlers to control the camps
and there was mass scale torture and execution.
It’s shocking enough on its own but the
fact that it was less than a decade since
the horrors of Nazi Germany had come to light,
the hypocrisy was probably the main reason
why the stories and documents were buried.
It’s thought that over 20,000 Kenyans died
and some 5000 more tortured.
Barrack Obama’s grandfather, Hussein Onyango
Obama, had pins forced into his fingernails
and his testicles squeezed between rods, while
two other men with him were castrated.
You see, the UK & US really do have a “special
relationship”, we go way back.
It wasn’t until 2011 that a landmark court
case, of Kenyan victims against the British
government, brought much of the evidence to
light.
It turned out that many documents had been
kept in a government building in Hanslope
Park, probably brought back by colonials who
disagreed with what was happening and wanted
it on record that they had complained.
So, it just goes to show, you can’t always
trust the men in blue, and remember, you always
have a voice, so if you’re being oppressed,
speak up for yourself – unless the men in
blue are pointing guns at you, then you should
probably shut the hell up.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.